je voulais avoir antoine jouteau antoine
choteau le patron du du bon coin en
touraine que je connais pas
personnellement mais je sais qu'ils
habitent au lit la ccao à côté des lilas
c'est ça tu habitais oliva toujours mon
antoine pas alors tu t'es raser la tête
en fait un pur voilà pendant le contenu
de cet effet un nouveau look a été
d'aller la coupe que vit un vrai bon et
tata vacances en été pas mal un cul
ouais tout va bien ouais c'est parce que
je sais que c'est mon papa qui soigne
absolument
ouais voilà j'ai c'est qu'il a été
malade d'ailleurs d'être je sais je sais
qu'ils espèrent qu'ils s'occupent bien
de toi
en quoi tu joues tous les cas vous êtes
alors je te tutoie mais c'est vrai que
parce que j'ai l'impression de te
connaître voilà mais vous êtes le patron
du bon coin parce qu'on se connaît pas
du tout c'est la première fois qu'on se
voir au toit des mois et c'est vrai
qu'on en avait on savait que séché avec
mon père de soigner mais je l'avais
jamais rencontré dont vous êtes le
patron du bon coin et j'avais envie de
ce soir voilà de donner la parole à ces
à ses patrons voilà qui font des choses
en ce moment et qui vivent là on essaie
d'être utile aussi est ce que vous
pourriez vous expliquer ce que vous avez
mis en place avec le bon coin oui alors
ce qu'on a mis en place sur le bon coin
c'est une initiative permet à nos
utilisateurs à tous les français de
proposer une annonce local bénévolement
de soutien aux personnes qui sont
fragilisés en grande difficulté dans
cette période
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire proposer
d'aller faire des courses pour des
personnes âgées ça veut dire aller
chercher leurs médicaments à la
pharmacie du soutien scolaire promener
les animaux domestiques voilà ça
s'appelle le bon geste c'est à saisir
son fils annonce dans le titre ça
s'appelle le bon geste et puis ça prend
quelques secondes et c'est un coup de
main tout en respectant évidemment les
respects et les règles de confinement et
de les gestes barrière mais vraiment
c'est un coup de main parce
qu'aujourd'hui les personnes en
difficulté elle souffre et elles sont
encore plus d'exploser dans ce moment
donc en fait en plus des petites
annonces le site se transforme aussi
maintenant pour aider des poils et
d'aider des personnes voilà donc bravo
bravo antoine jouteau d'avoir fait
d'avoir mis en place a alors le principe
de votre démarche et vous lancer aussi
le hashtag hashtag le bon geste
il ya ça aussi voilà pour qu'on puisse
voilà retrouver voilà des bonnes actions
il peut essayer de faire les bonnes
actions essayé peut-être d'aidé voilà
des personnes âgées je vous dis comme
vous avez dit à faire des courses etc
je voulais mettre ça en lumière parce
que chaque soir on mettra une bonne
action en lumière et ce soir c'est vrai
qu'on a choisi
nos chefs d'entreprise qu'on a examiné
royaux aussi vice-président de
mcdonald's france qui est avec nous
merci d'être avec nous michi toujours
merde merci alors xavier c'est un autre
tout parce que moi j'avais vu des photos
lui aussi sur google lui on voit voilà
qu'il est bien confiné qui ne sort plus
kebbi il a même il a plus de thon 2 1 je
vois cela c'est à dire et qui revient de
koh lanta xavier royaux
ça va bien et xavier chavalerin de la
syrie le merci à vous merci d'être avec
nous dit bravo pour ce que vous faites
parce que c'est vrai que ça c'est
important
racontez-moi l'initiative de deux magots
depuis le début du confinement on a
cherché nous aussi être utile donc utile
parce qu'on savait faire en modestement
par an pendant tout ce qui se passe
c'est la première chose qu'on avait
voulu faire c'est exprimer ma gratitude
aux personnels soignants comme tous les
français je pense qu'ils font c'est
admirable et donc là encore une fois
c'est un tout petit geste mais tous les
matins nous équipe livre le petit
déjeuner donc un petit moment de douceur
un petit moment des journées qui soit on
imagine harassante
donc c'est pas grand chose mais en même
temps on se devrait de le faire et
d'apporter tous les matins comme ça dans
plus de 50 chf le petit déjeuner un bras
au personnel soignant
et puis il ya ces comptes aussi voilà
moi je vais je vais postuler un jeu mais
on l'est je vais lire à l'antenne demain
et je vous le dis elle racontez nous
comment nettoyer les masques pour les
enfants et ça c'est important aussi
parce que c'est vrai que mine de rien ce
confinement on va pas se mentir je crois
que j'en parlais tout à l'heure encore
avec des potes ciric plus rien ne sera
plus jamais comme avant avec se confirme
alors bien sûr il ya plein plein plein
de mauvaises nouvelles qu'on apprend
tous les jours donc on essaie voilà de
vous divertir tous les soirs également
mais il ya aussi des moments où on
retrouve aussi sa famille on retrouve
des gestes qu'on faisait pas avant on
fait plein de choses en famille on fait
la cuisine ou regardent des films
ensemble on se réunit on retrouve aussi
on se retrouve je trouve un peu
humainement on retrouve un peu l'humain
c'est vrai qu'on est tous normalement ou
sur nos tablettes ou au bureau ou
toujours occupée là j'ai l'impression
qu'on prend plus le temps même pour les
autres donc si ça peut durer après le
confinement ça serait génial aussi et ça
m'aidera aussi c'est une initiative
aussi pour être encore voie la plus
proche de ses enfants voilà moi je sais
que voilà mine de rien j'ai envie de
faire beaucoup plus de choses avec mes
enfants apprennent confinement parce que
je me dis c'est vrai que je laisse
passer trop de temps et que mineur il
faut il faut aussi profiter d'eux
diallo c'est vrai que toute l'année
normalement il ya plein de jolis moments
aux familles dans nos restaurants d'un
coeur en ce moment aux énergies l'ozone
est avec ses enfants donc on a voulu
poursuivre ce qu'on fait depuis des
années maintenant qui consiste à offrir
des livres dans le happy meal et donc on
a offert ses livres via nos réseaux
sociaux ils sont en téléchargement
gratuit
comme ça les parents peuvent se
retrouver pour les lire avec les enfants
les enfants peuvent les lire en ligne
pour les plus grands et on a eu la
chance de bénéficier pour ça aussi du
partenariat d'hachette et katherine
pancol qui écrit ces histoires avant que
les agresseurs mais alors quatre grosses
non seulement si vous adorez crise
aujourd'hui elle nous a fait un cadeau
supplémentaire
elle a enregistré un compte elle-même
qu'elle est là fort en audio sur tous
nos réseaux et donc on invite aussi non
les parents de leur côté à merci et bah
tu sais quoi
xavier jean frère toi tu sais quoi série
à bari avec branchement vous les emplois
avec plaisir je voudrais leur dire bravo
et en plus là là on va faire un truc
c'est qu'on va appeler quelqu'un en
france
voilà je vous le dit et on va aller lui
offrirait les pas du tout au courant on
va appeler une personne comme ça voilà
on va voir et on va lui offrir un an de
mcdo d'accord un an de mcdo merci à
xavier parce que c'est un homme agglo
moi si je veux faire ça ne les enfants
il aurait été comme des fous non mais
mes enfants je voulais qu'ils peuvent
manger me fois on peut avoir démis
restaurant il passe devant mc do ils
veulent quand même y aller ça veut dire
que c'est un truc de fou que j'avais un
problème vous ou pas ici j radio el
bahdja mal à mes enfants
non mais alors ma femme est en 2 du
double cheese et me dit je pense qu'à ça
elle est enceinte et me dit je veux plus
ancienne de bêtises
c'est un drame pour elle vraiment je
vous le dis clairement que je lui offre
pas un an mais deux jours semaines le
truc merci pour elle merci pour je
voulais bien un truc on est 3 avec trois
enfants là effectivement c'est pour eux
la récompense en fait rien un mcdo c'est
waou
nous on va leur dire on la cuisine et on
va faire un truc bon est ce qu'on peut
vraiment avoir un mac do et là ils sont
complètement transhistorique on va
s'écrire en même temps ça leur fait du
bien quoi